when i started out
i had some resistance to rewrites
and it's important to understand that
when you resist it's because you're
scared of it
what writing process do you teach your
students
i try to teach my students um
give them as many different tools as
possible um
i don't believe in any darkness i don't
believe there's one single way to do it
um
when i teach
so for example i have a whole class for
a three-hour class for structure
and i give give them all the approaches
i know to structure like the you know
the save the cat approach to it and the
blake snyder approach to it uh the eight
sequence
structure
whatever it's whatever helps
they find helpful to break so it's not
so daunting to break down story because
um we all feel it you know when you when
you're facing the story you're like oh
my god i have so much ground to cover
and i don't know
so for example the eight sequence
structure is really helpful because
you're thinking in terms of
12 15 pages at a time
so you're no you're writing shorts i'm
talking about features of course um
it's like writing uh short units
um and then
by thinking of units you're not thinking
about the whole thing
um
with um with tv
well tv i mean there is
there are multiple ways to do tv but um
you know i do give them i do compare tv
structure with film structure in the
sense that um a drama pilot
you know the end of the teaser
is usually the inciting incident
um the end of act um
one
is where it kind of gets personal so the
the end of act two would be the midpoint
in a 60 minute 55 minute
um pilot
um
but i you know i i don't believe there's
one way to do things i whatever works
for each person
do you ever find students challenge
that
because they've they've read books
before they've taken your class or
they've taken other classes and they say
well then this is actually how it's done
and they like those rules they like
structure
i do believe there should be structure i
mean they don't usually question me
because they understand that i'm
i'm very straightforward from the
beginning and i said look i'm going to
give you
everything i know
and
sometimes you know there are different
options but
i'm
no i mean they're adults so i'm giving
them an option it's like i'm not going
to tell you there's one single way to do
it i'm going to tell you all the ways i
found out over the years and some of my
colleagues prefer this version and
others this one
and um
you know it's my my role as an
instructor is to give them tools not to
give them the ultimate truth because
there's no such thing
actually i would say the most important
thing
i don't know if you can teach people how
to write you can teach them discipline
you can encourage them
you can show them that it's not
impossible
um
you you can share experience you know
experiences that that reveal that
um you can get frustrated and keep going
you can have failures and get up
it's amazing how many times everyone
including myself and everyone else we
tend to think that what happens to us is
only
happening to ourselves
and it's ridiculous because
it's very
[Music]
liberating to hear that other people
have gone through the same
actually you don't all you don't you
never get
you rarely get a chance but if you can
read first drafts by acclaimed writers
which of course you'll never find
because they don't want you to
but um
academy award
writers winning writers also have awful
first drafts
they also have scripts that don't work
um
you know it's it's not that they sit
down and write the most perfect script
ever it takes many rewrites
so i mean i know aaron sorkin will go on
and say like he wrote uh the social
network in three months
i'm like maybe i don't know you know i'm
sure he's very talented and smart and
qualified i'm saying you know we all
need time to get there
is that something that's hard for your
students to accept or or
was that something for you in the
beginning that you just wanted to get
this
idea out there these characters out
there you didn't want to have to do
multiple drafts
um
you mean if if they challenged the idea
of of rewrites sure or did you yourself
challenge it um
i well when i started out um
i had
some resistance to rewrites
and it's important to understand that
when you resist it's because you're
scared of it
and i would say it is
it is scary because um
the first draft once you understand that
the first draft is not the final product
um it's just your first approach to it
um
then you understand that the rewrites is
where it actually gets tricky
and you know there are many
ways to approach rewrites
it took me a while to learn how to do it
as well
i usually use the image it's it's like a
wound you know it's a scar that you're
reopening
and being being very dramatic here but
you know you finish the draft and you're
very pleased then you want to step
back
right and take some distance
and then you go back to it and you have
to reopen the wound and like
it's all bloody again
and then you have to stitch it up again
um
i i think that's when you need
perspective the most
that's when you could use feedback from
close people
um
conversations maybe even the help of a
script doctor at some point why not
it's really hard to
have perspective on your own writing
sometimes you need some time to go by
maybe weeks or a month before you dive
in again
and you need someone's perspective to
know what works and what doesn't and and
maybe you love a scene and that scene
needs to go
and you need someone to tell you that
scene needs to go
um the good thing about working for hire
working with with uh with people is that
they actually give you
notes
and i could spend hours talking about
notes themselves and sometimes
they'll give you the best notes
and it hurts because you have to work a
lot on them but they're good notes you
can tell
and sometimes you gotta find the note
behind the note
you know some you don't you can't expect
people always to have the perfect note
to give you but it's your job to find
out what they mean
um and also i you know i try to be very
careful when someone has one opinion
okay i'll see if i consider or not but
when one note keeps coming up over and
over again
in different manners right but it's the
same note well then there's a problem
you know right when
i a script i have to rewrite now that i
rewrote a couple of times
it's a period script and
a note i kept getting back was
the main character is an [ __ ]
why do i care
and at first i resisted saying like no
it's the 60s that's how people did
things back then
but then you know when i keep getting
the same notes especially from female
readers
they're like no that guy's an [ __ ]
well then i have a problem because i'm
not making a movie for the 60s i'm
making a movie for nowadays
so even though i'm trying to be very
accurate in terms of how i portray the
period
my audience is now
so i got to do something about it
so
you had to make the character
somewhat more relatable and human
to today's standards not
um 60s well i mean he's a guy who's
focused on
on his work
and is is um
disregarding his
he's very young his wife is also very
young and they have a baby so instead of
being a good father which he can't
because he's like he's too young he
doesn't know i mean it's not he means
anything by it he just doesn't know how
to do it
so he escapes family his family's
responsibilities by focusing on his work
um
and the note was he's being an [ __ ]
i'm like no well he's a kid you know he
doesn't know
he shouldn't have been a dad in the
first place it's the 60s back in the 60s
you didn't share that responsibility
they're like no i don't care
you know i don't care how good he is at
his job
he left her alone to raise a child
and you know there's really no point in
me arguing that
what about don draper
well
this is the thing i i love mad men and i
love don draper and i use that as a
reference
don draper only works for today's
audiences because uh jon hamm is really
sexy
okay that's fair enough uh yeah i
remember
back when it came out i was watching it
with my girlfriend at the time and
i would say you know he's he's
disgusting he's an awful person and she
would be like i don't care he's too hot
and you know what there's a point there
i don't know how that they got that that
show made before casting
i think it took a while um
yeah he's awful he's a broken man but
he's jon hamm in a suit